[Music]
a Keith Olbermann in this is the
resistance the most deadly adversaries
of republican government might naturally
have been expected to make their
approaches from more than one quarter
but chiefly from the desire in foreign
powers to gain an improper ascendant in
our councils how could they better
gratify this than by raising a creature
of their own to the chief magistrate
recei of the union not my words they are
those of Alexander Hamilton writing in
the newspaper of the New York packet in
its issue of Friday March 14th 1788 the
Federalist Papers number 68 the one
explaining how the President of the
United States would be elected Alexander
Hamilton 83 thousand five hundred and
forty-nine days ago
predicting the Russian attempt to decide
our 2016 election for us and install
their own stooge Donald Trump to the
chief magistrate II of the Union how
could they better gratify this than by
raising a creature of their own a
creature of their own indeed as if
Hamilton was peering through time and
seeing Trump's preening face and evil
soul a creature of their own in the
Federalist number 68 Hamilton was
explaining how in the new constitution
the much debated concept of the
electoral college would preclude another
country from putting its man in our
presidency how it would make bribing the
electors nearly impossible
how it would also serve as protection
against scoundrels and traitors talents
for low intrigue and the little arts of
popularity may alone suffice to elevate
a man to the first honours in a single
state but it will require other talents
and a different kind of merit to
establish him in the esteem and
confidence of the whole Union or of so
considerable a portion of it as would be
necessary to make him a successful
candidate for the distinguished office
of president of the United States
talents for lo intrigue the little arts
of popularity Alexander Hamilton saw
everything phony about Donald Trump
except his hair Hanson of course
describes a different electoral college
than that which meets next Monday the
one hamilton wrote about in 1788 existed
before
there was any popular voting there were
no political parties no pledged
delegates no rubber stamp it is a
different Electoral College from the one
that is our last defense against the end
of America different except in spirit
for if the electoral college is not
still what Hamilton described it is
still what Hamilton intended it is there
to weed out the unqualified the
unprincipled the merely famous and
especially to weed out a creature of
foreign powers or in Donald Trump's case
all of the above but still a rubber
stamp a quaint vestige of the fact that
you have to win States not just votes to
become president oh if it's a rubber
stamp why does it convene if the
electoral college is merely a formality
in which the electors vote as the vote
totals in their states tell them to why
are the electors there certainly the
certified results from each state are
sufficient to declare Trump 3:06 Clinton
232 if the electoral college is merely a
vestige of state demographics in which
the electorate as the vote totals in
their states tell them - why is it legal
in nearly half the states 21 for the
members to vote for whoever they want
the answer would seem obvious I'll be it
kind of hard to believe never in our
history have any of our leaders fought
to amend the electoral college we have
changed the Constitution to permit women
to vote and slavery to be ended and for
alcohol to be banned and then changed it
back for alcohol to be unbanned we have
changed the Constitution to include
something the founding fathers quickly
discovered they had left out the entire
Bill of Rights but never in our history
have we altered the fact of the vote by
the electoral college thus there is only
one conclusion it is there because the
founding fathers were right someday we
would need it someday perhaps centuries
later we would need to follow Alexander
Hamilton's version of in case of
emergency break glass someday perhaps
century laters talents for lo intrigue
and the little arts of popularity would
combine with the desire in foreign
powers to elect their own present
and only the quaint irrelevant rubber
stamp of the electoral college the
appendix of the body politic would stand
between us and Armageddon turned out
someday was Monday December 19th 2016 it
is correct that 38 Trump electors voting
instead for Hillary Clinton would make
her present it is also correct that it
is likely er that the Electoral College
will be hit by an asteroid during its
convention next Monday then that 38
Republican electorate vote instead for a
Democrat the country has long since
become the land of me-first
and to find 38 political men and women
of true self-sacrificing patriotism and
conscience in the Republican Party would
at least quadruple the number of them I
could name right now Russians could have
literally instead of merely remotely
swung the election for Trump they could
be standing and Cossack uniforms along
Pennsylvania Avenue and Republican
politicians would still think but what's
in it for me before they switch from
Trump to somebody else but there is
another way there are compromises this
nation exists probably to die on January
20th when a foreign backed usurper
seizes power but for now this nation
exists because of the second civil war
we did not have the one that threatened
to explode in the winter of 1876 77 over
the disputed election between Rutherford
B Hayes and Samuel Tilden the election
was to be decided by Oregon Louisiana
South Carolina and Florida those states
sent two entirely separate sets of
returns to the electoral college one
favoring the Republican one favoring the
Democrat and the lame-duck president
increased the presence of troops in
Washington because it was assumed that
whoever lost was going to start shooting
but he didn't we compromised it was an
awful compromise the impact of which was
still felt ninety years later the
Republicans got the White House the
Democrats got the end of Reconstruction
in the south and tacit permission to
disenfranchise blacks and they're
descended upon us 90 years and more of
segregation and Jim Crow yet the threat
of civil war vanished and has stayed
vanished until now at least compromise a
resident scholar from the Cato Institute
named Michael
and wrote in The Washington Post on the
5th of this month suggesting that
instead of holding out hope of 38 Trump
electors miraculously risking their
status in their party just for the sake
of you know democracy the hero this time
should be Hillary Clinton her electors
not Trump's should vote differently she
should instruct those pledged to her to
vote instead for a moderate Republican
while Patriots in that party find 38 or
more Trump supporters to switch to that
same moderate Republican Canon suggested
Mitt Romney one could make a list a
small list Romney and John McCain and
eben McMullen and for that matter if he
were a little healthier President George
HW Bush Romney McCain McMullen whoever
presumably with a moderate Democrat as
vice president would it be right would
it be fair before you answer answer this
would it be a victory over the Russians
who committed an act of war against us
by interfering with our elections would
it be defense against Trump and this
banana Republican government of his
which will turn the rest of the world
over to Vladimir Putin and oh by the way
and our democracy and before you answer
even that answer this you can't have
Clinton Alexander Hamilton is dead the
alternative is an unelected dictator
would you right now trade Donald Trump
for a president Mitt Romney or a
president John McCain or a president
Evan McMullen me in a heartbeat and I
would then drop to my knees in thanks
for the electoral college resist peace